bonjour on va revenir ensemble sur ce
qui s'est passé pour moi en 2019 tena d
assez dingue il s'est passé plein de
choses très surprenant est resté jusqu'à
la fin de jal bêtisier d'années ça c'est
très important et puis ce matin tu es
tombé un cinglant oui bien procuré
mais il ya surtout les annonces sur ce
qui va arriver en 2020 tous les trucs
que je prépare et je pense que ça va
vous plaire puisque je travaille dur
dessus donc ya pas de raison on perd pas
de temps ces partis janvier 2019 qu'est
ce qui se passe je termine les dédicaces
de ma bd roger et c'est humain tome 2
voilà chalet un petit peu partout en
france je vous ai rencontré et j'ai eu
plein de cadeaux et des seins ça c'est
vraiment morte et ça m'a fait très
plaisir et il va y avoir un petit
teasing là dessus sur roger d'ailleurs
resté présent je perds ma vidéo et c'est
ma première fois au festival d'angoulême
pour moi c'était une vraie révélation
c'était super d'être là ce festival de
la bande dessinée m'a toujours fait
rêver
hélas d'être présent pour faire des
dédicaces et présenter le tome 2 de ma
bd c'était vraiment génial j'ai
rencontré plein d'auteurs trop bien j'ai
fait une vidéo où je parle de la
roumanie la mère patrie de toute ma
famille je la burqa reste donc du coup
je vous ai un petit peu partager mes
sentiments et les trucs qui m'ont fait
marrer là-bas la viande c'est pas
automatique
parlez-en à votre rouge la vidéo se
termine par des images de bucarest
capitale avec une petite musique
composée par théo beernaert une reprise
de ozone bref c'est un petit moment
politique à la fin de la vidéo si vous
n'avez pas vu je vous invite à regarder
et là c'est le drame la pièce roméo et
juliette avec bakary koné squeeze le
gage de l'impossible voilà faut savoir
j'étais plutôt réticent à l'idée de
faire cette pièce puisque dans mon
tempérament j'aime bien faire quelque
chose quand il est terminée calibre et
dont je suis fier que je maîtrise touche
de tout compris et là c'était tellement
le bordel et l'inconnu que j'étais
l'agent rap ok les gars on va faire de
la mer mais on y va franchement qu'est
ce qu'on fait bilan c'était une très
belle aventure ce qui est très étonnant
c'est qu'on s'est beaucoup amusé sur
scène même si le stress tu dis [ __ ] on
va pas être à la hauteur mais au final
tu t'éclates les imprévus c'est trop
drôle puis voilà ça s'est très bien
passé avec les gars on arrive ensuite
avec le clash avec squeeze la course aux
abonnés on a regardé les statistiques
avec lui car on s'est dit [ __ ] t'as
chaîne va dépasser la mienne dans pas
longtemps qu'est ce qu'on fait on a
décidé de faire un truc très fun on a
tout planifié des sort d'un faux clash
quoi en quelque sorte avec moi qui veut
mettre un sticker sur sa porte la gueule
de squeeze en énorme dans le métro à
paris je sais pas si vous êtes au
courant mais il ya une pub pour ma
chaîne sur la chaîne de squeeze pendant
un jour êtes au courant de ça ça coûte
une fortune
squeeze coûte très cher les clips de
clash c'était très drôle faut savoir
qu'on a tourné les deux clips dans la
même journée
voilà c'est moi qui ai réalisé les clips
et la potée
11 lucas passe devant avec un compteur
et c est le petit clip de réconciliation
tout va bien ne vous inquiétez pas pour
la promo du film d'hommes beau j'ai
rencontré eva green et tim burton qu'un
de mes réalisateurs préférés pouvoir ce
sujet pour me raconter pendant tout ce
début d'année je prépare donc court
métrage minori que je tourne au japon
avec françois descraques voilà donc on a
avancé de fou sur l'écriture le casting
à distance au japon etc et bien sûr le
tournage qui a été une des plus grandes
expériences professionnelles de ma vie
dans un pays que j'adore lui aussi
rencontrer des auteurs de manga là bas
notamment inio asano voilà qui est un
auteur de manga que j'apprécie
énormément et le court métrage sort est
là c'est pour moi une grande fierté
puisque jeu très content de ce court
métrage et sentiment qu'on a voulu faire
passer mélange de la culture européenne
avec la culture japonaise il ya eu plein
plein de fanart de minori et ça je
trouve ça génial voilà en tout cas c'est
un des plus gros projets que j'ai fait
dans l'année 2019 et j'en suis très
fière et puis j'ai eu plein de davie et
critiques sont très positives ya eu des
gens qui sont retournés sur les lieux du
tournage de ces géniales les jours vous
êtes incroyables cette année j'ai lancé
un nouveau truc qui est un petit peu
inattendu de ma part j'ai lancé une
émission en live sur tout cas voilà
s'appelle 300 une vue toutes les
semaines
j'accueille des invités qui viennent de
youtube ou du net et on parle un petit
peu d'actualité du tube et des
nouveautés et des trucs qu'on a envie de
voir partager etc et surtout le coeur de
l'émission c'est les anecdotes gênante
les trucs qu'il soit arrivé
toujours un peu de mal à en parler il
devance a avalé un petit garçon qui est
au premier rang est allé dehors et genre
sa mère était trop gêner les gens rient
pleurent mais les relais remet de
crocodile coach et moi c'est parce que
je voulais dire enfin a nommé est le
bienvenu je suis très content de cette
émission j'ai reçu plein de gens que je
connaissais que je connaissais pas et ça
va continuer sinon il ya mon autre
chaîne qui s'appelle l'autre chaîne de
ses prières où il ya tous les best-of
des émissions que vous pouvez visionner
tranquillement sur youtube et il ya
aussi le podcast sur spotify avec ton en
dessous
les pour écouter l'émission 2019 c'est
quand même pas mal d'années de la
perruque puisque j'ai beaucoup incarner
le personnage aux cheveux longs et donc
les instagram euse summer édition ça
c'est très drôle à faire avec audrey à
la plage garde un très bon souvenir
surtout on a enterré avec du sable dans
le cul et où bref c'était horrible mais
très fun à faire
j'ai fait aussi d'autres vidéos plus
simple à faire c'est pas trop dans mon
habitude de faire ce genre de petits
trucs mais parfois j'ai envie donc j'ai
parlé du top 10 de mes livres préférés
j'ai aussi parlé de mes chaînes youtube
préféré aime ce genre de vidéo qui
risque de peut-être arriver de temps en
temps sur ma chaîne youtube entre des
sketches ou des courts métrages tarifs
je me suis remis un petit peu au dessin
donc j'ai un compte instagram spéciale
où je pose mes dessins et surtout j'ai
expérimenté la réalité augmentée j'ai
créé des dessins qui sortent un peu des
bref c'est l'arrêté augmentés quoi c'est
ça ça sort dans la vidéo c'était très
fun je sais pas si je vais faire encore
des dessins d'ô jour là mais pourquoi
j'aimerais beaucoup faire un filtre
instagram si vous voyez un truc un peu
bizarre sortir sur mon instinct c'est
que j'ai sorti un filtre sigéric on
arrive en septembre c'est la rentrée
donc là je prépare des trucs qui vont
arriver je vous en parle un petit peu
plus tard mais d'abord je suis jury d'un
festival un concours de vidéos réalisées
par ces listes compte ça c'était une
super expérience de voir ce que les gens
peuvent créer sur youtube et de voile à
donner son avis et créer un petit
classement choix c'était une super
expérience
et là on arrive sur du gros sketch on a
fait les réunions 4 avec julien et
ludovic c'était génial affaire d'autant
plus que je me suis dit peut-être on va
se lasser un peu de ce format là c'est
le quatrième épisode est en fait non ça
ne nous a en fait donné encore plus
d'idées on est allé encore plus loin
c'est mon épisode préféré les pubs
versus la vie numéro 4 également
l'appareil en fait je me suis dit [ __ ]
mais on va se lasser en fait les pubs
sont tellement nul que ça nous a éclaté
dès parodier est pareil c'est je pense
mon épisode aussi préféré encore une
petite perruque on s'en lasse pas c'est
le retour de alice et zoé voilà les
instagram euse cette fois ci à la
montagne quand on a sorti la summer
édition dans les commentaires que l'on a
dit on veut la winter édition a du coup
voilà ça nous a éclaté de le faire tout
simplement j'aimerais vraiment remercier
la ville de chamonix et la compagnie des
alpes qui nous a accueillis pour le
tournage donc voilà ça nous a vraiment
facilité les choses de tourner sur des
pistes sachant que les pistes ne sont
pas ouvertes voilà et là on arrive à la
fin de l'année on a sorti un jeu de
loups garous dans une
the witcher sponsorisé par netflix et
c'était trop fun à faire c'était
vraiment dingue
j'adore cette vidéo elle est très
différent de ce que je fais sur ma
chaîne mais je trouve qu'elle a une
saveur particulière parce qu'en fait on
partage un moment avec le plein de potes
c'est vraiment cool dans des costumes et
des décors qui sont quand même
absolument dingue donc voila merci
netflix pour la confiance et on termine
l'année avec mon dernier projet qui est
un projet secret qui est le tournage de
mon prochain court-métrage qui va sortir
dans quelques semaines dans deux mois je
crois ce court métrage la gelée réalisé
également voilà ce qui est assez rare
parce que noir avec des réalisateurs
mais celui-ci j'ai réalisé c'est un
petit peu comme faire veut également
réaliser les plus courts là c'est un
projet beaucoup plus ambitieux j'espère
que ça va vous plaire et surtout j'ai
incarnent deux personnages à l'intérieur
vous allez comprendre quand ça sortira
si vous aimez pas ma gueule ça est
compliqué parce que là je fais deux
personnages et surtout en 2019 j'ai
participé aussi au projet d'autres
personnes j'ai participé à rebouc up de
john rachid jam de julien josselin j'ai
fait un peu de cuisine avec pierre
sangle le chef qu'on ne présente plus
des petites vidéos de mac faye carlito
où je me vautre en moto
[Musique]
arrêtez de vous moquer de moi moi et les
véhicules c'est compliqué j'ai participé
au lancement de la chaîne de dorothée
poussé aux sept comédiennes que j'adore
on m'a vu dans l'émission la bagarre de
mektoub
on voit aussi dans l'émission pons la
nuit voilà on passe quelques heures
ensemble avec l'ami prononce dans paris
l'émission le matin également qui se
passe le matin sur le stream c'était dur
de se lever et la série ds vous aime que
je vous invite à regarder
j'adore cette mini-série allez sur
youtube c'est gratuit vous pouvez foncer
voilà pour 2019 ça va clôturer avec un
petit bêtisier mais que va-t-il se
passer
en 2020 ouvrez nos écoutilles je sors un
jeu mobile qui était prévu pour 2010
hommes et qui sortira en 2020 ça
s'appelle make more views et c'est un
jeu où tu crées un youtube heures et tu
vas devoir avoir le plus grand studio
avoir des employés faire des featuring
te faire démonétisé faire de plus en
plus de vidéos à voir de plus en plus de
matériel
ce sera un jeu gratuit je reviens dessus
bientôt le court métrage qui va sortir
dans quelques semaines j'en ai parlé
tout à l'heure que j'ai tourné en fin
décembre
là on arrive sur des projets qui sont
plus confidentiels je vous dis juste que
je peux vous dire je vais avoir un
dessin animé sur ma chaîne youtube en ce
moment je cherchais financement mais ça
devrait arriver cet été un petit extrait
maintenant plus ou encore un tout petit
bout voilà ça c'est juste pour vous
donner l'eau à la bouche ça va arriver
bientôt sur ma chaîne je cherche de
l'argent voilà en ce moment et enfin
voilà ça c'est très confidentiel mais je
travaille sur un film qui sortira au
cinéma donc voilà pour l'instant je peux
pas trop vous dire ce que c'est comment
parce que il ya encore et encore du
boulot mais voilà ça m'occupe beaucoup
de temps donc c'est normal s'il n'ya pas
12 milliards de vidéos sur la chaîne
youtube c'est que je fais des petits
trucs à côté et rien à voir mais y aura
le tome 3 de bandes dessinées roger
c'est gmac sortir à la fin de l'année
2020 que vous dire de plus si ce n'est
qu'ils fait cette année 2020 donner tout
et c'est parti pour le bêtisier de
l'année 2010 ah oui et abonnés possible
ça y est la fhc mon premier bonhomme de
neige
[Musique]
brandt a nommé comme ça partisans de
chavez ont annoncé un chevreuil
[Musique]
c'est qui la meilleure époque il décède
oui c'est assez froid je pense que si tu
vois que gourmand tu fais tu vas battre
comme depuis ce matin et on est ensemble
oui bien sûr et futée habitent ou quoi
croyez quoi regarde notamment pas dessus
tu fais secondaire
donc c'est fini
ah oui j'ai fini oui bayal pied je fais
tu vois les jambes la wii eh ben c'est
pas des gens de cinéma non non non je
respire et pour cadeau au jeu désolé pas
quoi et c'est d'écraser la com
[Musique]